- This interaction started five years ago
when someone tagged us on Twitter
and asked if we're brothers.
And we do look alike. This is weird.
- There's definitely some similarities.
- We just took a photo with Bear
and we kind of look alike.
- [Manny] (chuckles) Yes, okay.
The photo, I will say-
- Who is the father?
- You are the father!
(beep)
- But now we're gonna
take your makeup knowledge
to the next level.
You're gonna have to answer some questions
and they're easy questions.
They're true or false questions
about makeup, and health, and skincare.
So you should rock this.
This shouldn't be a problem for you.
- Mhm.
- Every question you get right
I'm gonna donate 500 bucks to
the charity of your choice,
which you have predetermined to be...
- The LGBT Center in Los Angeles.
- I'm the inner beauty today.
He's the outer beauty.
- And I'm the outer.
Wait, that's actually so sweet and cute.
I love that.
- It's like a team thing.
(children cheer)
- We're launching merch
and Manny's gonna help me
launch merch by wearing it.
Trust me, I'm a doctor.
Dot, dot, dot.
- [Manny] I love that.
- Ooh! Can you say it?
- I can't even see it.
(record scratches)
- You don't know
the catch phrase of the channel?
- I do!
- Manny, you lied to me.
He told me he watches the channel.
And what's the weird sound that I make?
- Pee.
Peewoo.
Is that it?
Peewoop, there we go!
- [Both] Peewoop!
- Makeup or fake up, true or false.
You don't need to wear sunscreen-
- False.
- Let me finish.
- Okay. You're right.
- You don't need to wear sunscreen
if your makeup has SPF in it.
- I mean, I always am down
for a double layerage,
so I would say false still.
- Okay. That's a good point.
You are correct.
- 500.
- 500 bucks.
- But the double layer
thing is a little inaccurate
'cause it can confuse people.
You know why?
- Why?
- Because it's not additive.
SPF 15 on and then makeup
with SPF 15, it's not SPF 30.
So it's not additive. You
have to really make sure.
So I would say put on the
good quality SPF first
and then whatever your makeup has, great.
It's extra benefit.
- It's fine.
Right, right, right
- True or false.
You should apply your
sunscreen before your makeup.
- True. But you actually have
to apply it after, as well,
or after the time limit is done.
Like we can use a powder sunscreen,
a spray sunscreen, and
applying it after it.
'Cause the time still wears out.
You still have to do it before
and after while you're still wearing it.
- I should give you bonus points
'cause you not only answered it correctly,
but you got the extra part
that I was gonna say. But yes.
- But see the thing is
because I'm a professional.
- You are a professional
when it comes to sunscreen.
We're only two questions in!
True or false. Wearing makeup is bad
for the health of your skin.
Ooh. Hoo, he's thinking about it.
- I'll go ahead and say true
because wearing foundation,
powder, things like that,
it can clog your pores and
that can't be ever good.
So I'm gonna say true.
- False.
- Ew! I hate it.
- As long as you're taking it off.
- What if you're not?
- Okay, I mean, that's wrong.
- I'm competitive.
- You're not following the directions.
- I'm very competitive. That's my problem.
- Like if I say, "Is it
dangerous to drink water?"
- Piranha water.
- Do you drink piranha water often?
- I don't. It could be bad.
- Moral of the story,
number one, Manny's wrong,
number two, that as long as
you take off your makeup,
wearing it even often is not
problematic for your skin.
But make sure that you clean it off
to maintain the healthy skin
so that you don't clog your pores.
True or false.
(Manny groans)
- Makeup expires slash goes bad.
- A hundred percent true.
It expires because bacteria
can get inside of it.
It could be literally anything.
It's like we can't pump in mascara.
You're constantly putting air, bacteria,
things in the air floating.
- I don't need to even
be a part of this video
'cause he knows all the
answers. This is not fair.
Well, this is kind of the
opposite of medications, right?
Like over-the-counter
medications that are not life
or death can usually be used
after the expiration date.
But the medications that
you need for your life,
those need to be on par.
Because the danger of
medications expiring is
that they don't become as effective.
They don't grow bacteria,
they don't become bad for you,
they're just not useful.
But makeup can actually be
harmful when it expires,
not just not useful.
- Do I use expired makeup sometimes?
A hundred percent.
- Okay. Don't do what Manny does.
- I'm gonna be honest here-
- He's Manny, the bad makeup artist.
- When it comes to powders,
they expire way less quickly than creams
and liquids and anything
that's a little more wet.
- Well, 'cause fungi can get in there.
- Yeah, and start sporing.
- And they're not the
kind of fun guy that I am.
- That was pretty good, actually.
- [Sam] You wanna promote
the tour after that one?
- Yeah, no I don't.
'Cause then people are
gonna sell their tickets.
(Manny laughs)
Designer makeup is better for your skin.
- Nope. False.
I would it say depends
on the ingredient deck,
but you can have really, really
nice high-end ingredients
in drugstore makeup, the
same kind of ingredients
that could be found in
your high-end stuff,
depending on where the lab is made.
A lot of times a lab that makes,
let's say, Armani can be making
stuff from L'Oreal, as well.
- What's that commercial
that I always see on TV
with the guy with the melons?
He's obsessed with the melons.
- What are you talking
about with the melons?
- The guy's like, "I went to
France and I found this melon
and if you put the melon
cream on your skin..."
You've seen it.
- No, I literally don't know
what you're talking about.
- There's melons in France
that are apparently good
for your skin.
It's unhealthy to sleep
with your makeup on.
- True. Take that ish off.
- Yeah, so it becomes a problem,
like you said, clogging pores.
You're smearing all your
makeup all over your pillows.
So it's kind of gross.
But you know what the
biggest scam here is?
And it's not a scam. Let
me back up a little bit.
- Maybe it is.
- Choose my words carefully.
This company approached me to
try and sell silver sheets.
And you're like, these
are antibacterial sheets
so you don't get acne.
And I'm like, this is the most
ridiculous statement ever.
Are you telling people that
if they get these sheets,
they no longer need to wash them?
It's not like silver kills all bacteria.
- It doesn't harbor it, right?
- The bacteria doesn't harbor
as readily as other threads.
- I love seeing the little
Bear hairs flying everywhere.
- That's what adds flavor to the room.
- I can taste it. Literally.
- Be careful. If you eat
a lot of animal hair,
it can cause a bezoar.
This is-
(Manny gasps)
Yeah. That's not a stomach.
- I just felt so physically ill.
I don't think you understand.
I literally felt a little nauseous.
- True or false time.
Anti-aging wrinkle creams
actually remove wrinkles.
- Retinol does a good job at
minimizing wrinkles slightly.
I would say true then.
- They don't actually remove wrinkles.
They basically encourage cell turnover
to create more collagen.
- And so then the wrinkles become smaller?
- The appearance of it gets reduced.
- Gotcha. 'Cause I feel
like when I've used retinol,
I've noticed a difference.
- The soul
of the wrinkle hangs around.
- Oh, got it, got it, got
it. What in the Horcrux?
Not you being like, the
soul of the wrinkle.
- True or false, Manny.
True or false.
- You scared me!
- There is no need to wash a makeup brush
if you're the only one who uses it.
- False.
- Why?
- Because again, bacteria,
it gets nasty and dingy,
and if you're using the
same brush constantly,
that's still touching your face.
There's bacteria on your face
still going on the brush.
It's gonna have its own
little ecosystem in the brush
if you don't wash it.
- You know what's a good example here?
You're the only one who wears your clothes
and you wash them.
- Right. Oh my God, I didn't
even think about that.
- Same for makeup brushes.
- It's the truth.
You have to wash them.
- People with natural oily skin-
- Don't need to moisturize.
- Should use moisturizer.
- True. That's a big
misconception for a lot of people.
Like, oh, I'm oily, I
don't need moisturize.
No, you do. Maybe your
skin's over-producing oil
to compensate for how dry it feels.
- Where we see this happen quite often is
on the scalp, where some people are like,
oh, my scalp is very oily
so that means it's not dry.
And actually it could be
dry and it's producing a lot
of oil or there's a lot
of oil being produced
and then there's little
bacteria that eat it
and then cause inflammation
and flakes, et cetera.
So there's all sorts of
different variables here.
But what I will say is when
you put on a moisturizer,
you're helping your skin stay moisturized
and lock in that moisture.
Oil doesn't necessarily help you do that.
And you wanna use a moisturizer
to prevent rosacea, acne,
'cause if you have a breakage
in your skin barrier,
that's where the bacteria
gets in and all that stuff.
True or false.
The best and cleanest tool
for applying makeup is your fingers.
- If they're washed.
- I'm asking true or false.
- Oh my gosh. You know what?
I'm gonna go with true.
No, I'm not!
- No, that's it, sorry.
- It depends, Mike.
- Brush. You know brush
is the right answer.
- But what if the brush is dirty?
What if it's been used?
- Yeah, but we said the cleanest.
Are your fingers the cleanest?
- They can be.
- They can be, but are they?
- Sometimes when I would
do makeup on people
and I had washed my hands,
I would sometimes blend out
with my finger because it was clean.
- Yeah, but is that the best?
Or is that what you were doing in a rush?
- I think I was doing it in a rush.
- What?
- You're like (gasps).
- [Sam] I'm into the drama.
(both laugh)
(beep)
- True or false.
You can restore and continue using mascara
after it's dried up.
- You can. You can restore it.
You can restore it.
- False!
Manny, you just said the answer before!
- Listen, you can restore it, though.
- And now you're giving
people misinformation.
- No, but I was saying you can restore it.
- You said the bacteria.
You said the word.
- Okay, but I was listening to restore.
- Bacterium.
- You can restore.
- True or false.
It's safe to consume a small amount
of lipstick if it gets into your food.
- True. The thing is if you wear lipstick,
you're gonna constantly
be consuming it every day.
- But if a small amount
of it gets into your food.
- How much is a small amount?
- A decent amount.
- Okay. (laughs)
You guys! You guys.
- A decently small...
- What the hell does
that even literally mean?
(beep)
- I'm gonna answer the question medically,
then Manny can choose to
accept or not these results.
- I don't accept.
- Medically, some lipsticks contain lead,
which you do not want to eat
and that can be problematic.
- Then you shouldn't be wearing that kind
of lipstick at all. Period.
Wait, what lipsticks contain lead?
- These lipsticks contain lead.
- I'm gonna go and say that didn't count.
- Well, this is your
chance to make up for it.
True or false. Another food question.
- You said that the last
literal three times.
And I haven't made up for it.
- It's safe to consume a
small amount of nail polish
if you nibble on your fingernails.
- I'm gonna say false on that one.
I would say it's not safe.
I feel like nail polish
ingredients are even more intense
than lipstick ingredients.
- You're right.
- That sounds very chemically harsh.
- Good. True or false.
It's unsafe for children
and teens to wear makeup
because of the chemicals
on their young skin.
- I would say false.
- So you're saying it's safe.
- Yeah, I would say it's safe.
If an adult's using
it, why can't the kids?
- Explain yourself. Well,
they have young skin.
- What does young skin mean?
- I'm gonna reread the statement
and give him another chance
'cause he's confused.
It's unsafe for children
and teens to wear makeup
because of the chemicals
on their young skin.
- True.
- False.
- I hate you.
Literally, he's confusing the
(peewoop) out of me, dude.
- While children are at a higher risk-
- Children!
- And teens are higher
risk of complications
with their skin-
- I'm like, oh, 12, 13. They're children.
- Putting on makeup occasionally
and maintaining good hygiene,
there shouldn't be a problem
putting on the makeup.
- Okay, but when I was saying-
- Ethical and moral considerations aside.
- Of course.
- True or false.
Makeup with fewer ingredients
tends to be healthier.
- I would say false.
'Cause it depends on
what the ingredients are.
- Tends.
- Tense?
- Tens?
- Tends.
- What the hell are you-
what hell does that mean?
Oh, tends! Tends! I
thought you were saying 10.
I'm like, 10.
- Did I say it weird?
(upbeat dance music)
- Tens across the board.
So wait, read the question again.
- Okay. Makeup with fewer
ingredients tends to be healthier.
- Okay. I'll say true.
- It is true.
To me, why they tend to be healthier
is you can't hide a lot of BS
when you have a short ingredient list.
That's why with foods,
you wanna eat whole foods
because you know what you're getting.
And it doesn't necessarily
mean if there's a lot
of ingredients it's automatically bad,
it just tends to be easier to understand
and tends to be healthier.
- Tends. Tends.
- See, it's like an English lesson
and makeup lesson all in one.
- Tens across the board.
(upbeat dance music)
- We're all winning.
- If I'm, winning, you're winning.
- Especially the LGBTQ Center because
- They're earning some coin.
- You've won...
- [Sam] $5,000!
- $5,000!
- No way!
- Yeah, good job.
(Manny screams of excitement)
How about we leave them
with a parting thought
that they should watch you glam me up.
- Yes, on my channel.
- The video right here.
Click here for that video.
- On my channel. I'm
about to turn him into me.
- Point to it. Point to it.
- Right there.
Click here, check that out.
- Peewoop!
And as always, stay happy and
- Healthy.
- He knew the line!
He watches the end of the
videos but not the beginnings.
Okay.
(upbeat music)